thank you yasser we are with a lady that
is surging through the rankings right
now uh a consecutive victory for you
jennifer congratulations still a shaky
opening
yeah there's something this is just bad
there's nothing to say about it i was a
bit um so i when i prepped against her i
thought she was like she only played um
king's indian so i played d4 she plays
z5 and i'm like oh my god she's gonna
play queen's gamut
yeah and i was like okay i'll just do
something random so i played uh i played
bishop four because i was like i don't
think she knows how to play you know
kind of london instruction and i i mean
i've played this enough with black like
i was like i'll just do something and
then i didn't accidentally just
transpose to like the grunfeld and in
this position i know like i think the
line is dixie and then i was just i
don't know what i was thinking i just
thought i could do something to like
kind of
um not play into like theory but but
even after dxc it's like a wild theory
going on yeah
yeah
yeah that's exactly why i'm playing this
because you know i wasn't i didn't prep
into this going to the game i think
knight d7 don't allow bishop e5
yeah some wild theory i i think there's
some old games here yeah i've studied
this a while ago but you know i wasn't
really
i don't think she plays as either as
black but i just didn't want to get into
this so
um i thought
i realized like what i played was not
that great
now e5 is coming and everything opens up
how did you assess the position at this
point i mean i wasn't a big fan of my
position but i thought i could have some
practical chances just because you know
the night is pretty strong bishop
switched on but she had she got um a
really interesting idea here with bishop
b6 bishop of h6
and i wasn't sure exactly what to do
against this
um yeah knight takes a6 i wanted to take
on a but um
i just thought she looked awful so i
think it was the right decision not to
take it
yeah um yeah it just looked awful and
i thought you know i have some
compensation here just one question here
uh i think the boys were recommending
this move queen to a5 did you consider
it at all yeah i thought queen a5 was
better
um
and against this i'm not sure maybe uh
i can try before and then
um
the queen c2 but it looks really shaky
yeah
still a game
nevertheless still a game you still have
dark square
control so she took on a6 and that
allowed you to get the king to safety
which i'm sure you were happy about yeah
yeah i mean as soon as i took on d4 you
know i think i'm fine um and now i'm
just pushing
and then let's go towards the end
because there was some wild stuff going
on there
yeah we finished off quite nicely
let's go keep going
yeah i had a pretty easy win somewhere
and then i just
yeah here i could just take on h7 but i
i like i i play queen g there and i was
like oh queen takes h7 that's just the
fourth win but
yeah i mean i guess it's the winning
it's still winning
and
yeah rook horror was a good move
don't go bishop takes g6 were you uh
tempted about bishop takes g6 instead of
rook h4 well um it was the same thing
like a move ago if she played bishop b7
so i was kind of uh prepped this was our
initial uh move and then we realized
that queen takes h3 there's still a
bishop on c8 yeah yeah it was yeah that
was kind of
um that was the closest one but i guess
it all worked out
it did indeed uh a big victory for you
jennifer congratulations guys any
questions no just keep it up two zero
do two wins in a row
she seems like not such a nice person
we're being told
faith
i got this in the back menacing in the
other one
[Laughter]
congratulations jennifer two in a row
you feeling uh
good about your chances
um
i mean i got
yeah i mean i'm playing every game to
win so
um pretty happy i got to win the last
two games because the first two just
started off just very um i mean they
were they weren't the most interesting
games and i just messed up near the end
so
um
i just want to get some momentum going
and then
we'll see
all right well good to see that keep it
going rectified yes always good to see
jennifer play good chess with plenty of
games